un carton maria maria c'est déjà un
carton je vous le dis le premier album
de kenji s'était vendu à 1,3 million il
en perd y avait bien sûr ça
[Applaudissements]
on attend
pas nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
le tout ressemble au genou
et
neuf étrangers
[Applaudissements]
et je peux mettre duquel dix pendant une
heure et demie sans terre
ce n'est pas fini parce que on va porter
le nombre de tubes qui l'a fait en si
peu de temps que j'ai déjà là on en a on
en a quatre
regardez plus marié à maria spécial
s'est lassé de mes préférés c'est la
cool
[Musique]
deuxième album carton aussi avec près
d'un million d'exemplaires vendus
on y retrouvait une de mes chansons
préférées
là
kenji sur la tête de ma mère quand tu
comprends pas la chanson c'est un après
tout c'est qu'il est en voiture il s'est
embrouillé avec un homme qui naquit n'a
après les faits quand il sort la bonne
était arrivé de lagos et tout une
histoire dont souffre la priorité c'est
bruno becquet mots ça veut dire je me
chauffe avec la musique celui-ci vous
lire une petite musique un verre de
fanta citron ge oil & gas tu le vois
plus quoi ses yeux on peut quand même
dire que vous êtes son fan numéro à
chaque fois alors a fait dire il ya des
gens ici qui te lâche route ont déjà
lâché turati de maillé par exemple voilà
je sais qu'il a prises pour anne
roumanoff mais c'est gérable à la tâche
rappelez moi je ne lâcherai jamais